[Music]
Oprah was so inspired by a CBS news
story on a high school principal in New
Jersey that changing his students lives
that she decided to help in a very big
way earlier this year we introduced you
to New Jersey principle that's Akbar
cook
he started the lights on program at
Westside high school in Newark to give
students somewhere safe to hang out on
Friday nights
well last Friday Oprah then wit free
there she is showed up with a half a
million dollar donation in pizza from
her oh that's good line the press is
made of cauliflower by the way or
Polanski Bedell see I was there for the
very exciting announcement and so was
our lead national correspondent David
beg no that star power but oh there was
so much more to come the students didn't
know Oprah was coming but principal
Akbar cook did what he did know was what
else
Oprah wanted to give the media mogul was
inspired to get involved with the
school's lights on initiative after she
saw a CBS Evening News report back in
March Westside high school opens every
Friday night from 6:00 to 11:00 for kids
who use the school's gym to play games
and eat food in the summer it's opened
three nights a week
principal cook showed us five commercial
grade washers and dryers that he
installed so students who can't wash
their clothes at home can do it at
school Davion is a freshman Anthony is a
junior why do you choose to leave it for
the bachelor
so the lights go out
Oprah's $500,000 donation means that
Westside will keep the lights on all
summer for principal cook Oprah's gift
felt like an act of love love is
powerful you can underestimate the power
of love and this is what everyone has
been just showing even showing my kids
and and me and this community that they
did love oh man and it's going a long
way what's the lesson for us watching
what you did the lesson is that every
day there's a story that you can do
something about today actually did
something did you ever think you'd meet
Oprah
West Side High School Principal Akbar
cooks joins us at the table good morning
to you good morning I remember an Oprah
saw that story and saw you in particular
and said I really like that guy how do I
get in touch with that guy you knew it
was coming but were you still did you
still have doubts up into the last
minute yes you never know I mean coming
from the city just getting back and
forth is a task in itself and it was
five o'clock and still no did it was
seven o'clock it still hold the traffic
mr. Cook was so bad that Oprah said well
this is fine I'm just gonna sit here Zen
with my thoughts when we're in the car
an hour and a half later she goes how
much longer I gotta get there cuz
traffic was so bad but would you talk
about the difference it makes when kids
know and see that somebody cares we when
we got the Westside it was like the
Bermuda Triangle stuff went in and
didn't come out and we just started
being consistent and just started doing
it with love and you could see the
change and now even from even the love
that Oprah gave and and other people
from out the world my kids feel a sense
of pride now and it's making them want
to be that that that superstar student
and successful was citizen that we want
them to be and it's just all because of
love just being consistent and just
sticking with it and most time they
didn't have any bond so now you go all a
champion them and they and they fill it
you're going on the fourth year with the
lights on program this could be our
fourth summer haven't like someone who
say it's been a lifesaver for some kids
absolutely we opened it up because I had
lost three kids the gun violence and
since we opened it up during school you
haven't lost
anymore kids was there resistance from
kids about this or did they come right
away
they come right away it took its you
have to build trust yeah and when we
first started off it just was
basketballs and jump broke since yeah
and we had to you know you know do a
unpacking and really dig dig deep and we
realized that we needed to do more
things for the young ladies and once we
start doing that the guys the guys can
other principals reached out to you to
say hey how do you do this yes going
yeah yes so the big thing is we're going
to be out in LA at a school in watts and
Yale University contacted me they want
to do Haven Connecticut had been Las
Vegas I think has 300,000 students so
we're working with Clark County so yes
principal have been reaching out and I'm
trying to take the show on the road
because how dare I sit on something this
awesome and not shared with the way it
occurs to me that your story is the
second time we've had a wealthy donor or
Genesis it may give to a school what's
going on with schools today what what do
politicians not get or leaders not get
that is creating this problem where you
need some of them to give you something
to make your school work I just think
that we are thinking that parents are
there and it's not we have to be the
parent we have to be the social worker
we have to be the guidance counselor so
throwing resources in schools are are
giving it to the kids right where they
need it most and basic needs how can I
come to school if I'm not clean yeah I
don't I didn't brush my teeth like how
so we have to stop thinking about the
other stuff and get back to the basic
needs and start taking care man we
mentioned that you put in washing
machines how effective of that has that
been in making kids come to school
listen my freshmen I can't keep them
home I have my freshman like 94% average
daily attendance in my sophomores of
battling with them now in 94 so I say
look at my younger students my thing is
a still senioritis Anthony you make a
very good point I would have never
thought that washers and dryers would
make a difference and I love that you
call them your babies - yeah so with
opers money what will that do for your
program now allow you to do what Wow so
I can expand I still need to do more
just restorative things with the kids
like yes it's recreational what if I can
give them some educational resources and
just show them some life skills and soft
skills so they can be more employable to
employ
just anything I can to make them
successful and not just I know we all
want to extend the kid straight to
college but sometime these kids can't
they need to go right to the workforce
that's what this siblings and they own
children I love it it's a great story
just thrilled to do it the pizza was
good too maybe we'll call it flour I
heard cauliflower crust Prince Walker
thank you very much for joining us we
just for her that's a lot thank you